[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 1er décembre voici le programme
aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale de
lutte contre le sida l'occasion de
rappeler l'importance du dépistage du
VIH selon les derniers chiffres publiés
par santé publique France les personnes
de plus de 50 ans sont les plus
vulnérables alors comment se faire
tester comment se faire accompagner nous
en parlerons avec Jérôme André le
directeur général de HF prévention santé
c'est notre invité comme chaque année le
Téléthon revient le premier week-end du
mois de décembre moment de solidarité
pour la recherche contre les maladies
rares plusieurs événements sont
organisés dans le département nous en
parlerons avec Julie Ouchet la
coordinatrice du Téléthon dans le
secteur est des Yvelines et puis comme
d'habitude le jeudi à l'approche du
week-end nous vous donnerons nos idées
de aussi dans les Yvelines nous aurons
notamment une grande page sur Noël avec
les marchés à venir dans le département
et les activités à faire en famille à
l'approche des fêtes et avec moi en
plateau Gabriel Gontier bonsoir bonsoir
Mathilde de la rédaction de tv78 vous
allez nous présenter vos idées de sortie
pour ce weekend est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus oui Mathilde
comme chaque jeudi je vous ai préparé 5
idées de sortie à faire dans le week-end
alors on aura une grosse partie musique
avec l'Orchestre symphonique de Thoiry
notamment mais aussi de la littérature
ou encore des expositions avec le 150e
salon des artistes qui se tient à
Versailles en ce moment et on en parlera
plus en détail enfin des missions Noël
on en parlera aussi avec vous Philippe
Benassaya bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
porte-parole du Conseil départemental
des Yvelines et ce week-end aura lieu la
5ème édition du comptoir de Noël au
domaine de Madame Elisabeth à Versailles
qu'est-ce que pourront retrouver les
Yvelinois sur place plein de choses
plein de choses d'abord parce qu'il y
aura beaucoup de stands cette année près
de 90 ans de de cette année pour ce très
beau village de Noël avec beaucoup
d'activités gastronomiques beaucoup de
jeux pour les enfants dans le parc du
domaine Élisabeth donc c'est plutôt un
événement sympathique pour toutes les
familles et avec beaucoup beaucoup de
jeux cette année on a mis comme on dit
un peu le un peu le paquet et donc on en
parlera également en seconde partie
d'émission mais ce week-end se déroule
également le premier tour du congrès du
parti les républicains dans les Yvelines
les militants pourront voter pour le
futur président du parti dans les
Yvelines on fera le point avec vous dans
quelques instants avec nous également un
plateau Julie Ouchy bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes la coordinatrice du
Téléthon pour le secteur est des
Yvelines est-ce que tout est prêt pour
ce week-end tout est presque prêt on est
en train de de préparer la pâte à crêpes
de gonfler les ballons d'installer les
banderoles voilà là on est dans les
starting blocks et donc on parlera du
programme dans quelques instants
également avec nous un plateau Jérôme
André bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
général pas mal de HF prévention santé
cette journée c'est la journée mondiale
de lutte contre le sida elle existe
depuis
1989 pourquoi est-ce qu'elle est
toujours aussi importante aujourd'hui
cette journée bien malheureusement en
fait elle est toujours d'actualité
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait aujourd'hui
encore on meurt du sida et donc si
effectivement les gens ont des
traitements ils peuvent survivre mais
pour ça encore faut-il connaître son
statut sérologique et donc être dépisté
c'est tout le travail effectivement qui
est réalisé par plusieurs associations
et notamment aider donc par le ministère
de la Santé les agences régionales de
santé qui font en sorte qu'ils puissent
y avoir du dépistage du dépistage au
plus proche des populations comme le
fait HF prévention puisque je le
rappelle on organise 16000 dépistages du
VIH notamment dans les universités les
centres commerciaux et des cœurs de cité
là où effectivement donc il y a des
besoins et des nécessités et puis on va
comme vous le savez puisque vous êtes
souvent venus TV 78 avec nous dans les
parkings forêts d'autoroute où il y a
des besoins et plus que jamais on le
voit une épidémie peut en cacher une
autre une pandémie peut en cacher d'une
autre et là pour le coup le covid 19 a
fait donc il y a un ralentissement
aujourd'hui donc des dépistages des
découvertes donc santé publique France a
annoncé les chiffres 5000 découvertes il
en manque encore
2500 à 3000 si on avait les chiffres de
2019 on serait entre 6 et 7000
contaminations donc chaque année donc là
ça prouve bien qu'on a un souci de
dépistage et il faut plus que jamais
renforcer le dépistage donc on en
parlera dans quelques instants mais
juste avant je vous propose de regarder
la météo de demain
l'hiver s'installe dans les Yvelines
demain matin le ciel devrait rester
encore bien nuageux sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
couvrez-vous bien parce qu'il devrait
faire en moyenne 3 à 2 degrés dans
l'après-midi pas de gros changement le
ciel devrait rester couvert au niveau
des températures comptées 3 degrés en
moyenne dans les Yvelines et dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi quelques
flocons devraient faire leur apparition
dans les Yvelines le pour maintenant sur
l'actualité du jour
et c'est avec vous Céline Charles
bonsoir on en a parlé en début de
semaine c'était lundi que débuter le
procès du Val Fourré de Mantes-la-Jolie
au tribunal judiciaire de Versailles le
procès se termine aujourd'hui on connaît
maintenant les réquisitions alors
effectivement pour rappel le procès se
tenait pour dénoncer un système de
raquette présumé sur le marché du Val
Fourré lui prévenu était jugés cette
semaine après deux heures de prise de
parole la magistrate Pamela tabardell a
réclamé aujourd'hui des peines variant
de 18 mois à 5 ans de prison ferme sans
mandats de dépôt pour 7 des 8 prévenus
elle a également requis une interdiction
définitive d'exercer dans la fonction
publique ou de se rendre à
Mantes-la-Jolie pendant 5 ans pour
plusieurs prévenus concernant Sidi elle
Emer excellu Mr par intérim de
Mantes-la-Jolie le parquet a demandé une
année de prison avec sursis et une
énigibilité pendant 5 ans avis
maintenant aux fans de sport la
billetterie des Jeux olympiques de Paris
2024 est ouvert puis ce jeudi 1er
décembre alors attention ce n'est que la
première phase pour avoir une place il
va falloir être patient et chanceux il
faut d'abord s'inscrire sur le site
internet des jeux il y aura ensuite un
tirage au sort vous saurez dès le début
du mois de février si vous êtes
sélectionné si c'est le cas vous aurez
par la suite la possibilité d'acheter
des packs de billets on le rappelle un 5
épreuves se déroulent se dérouleront sur
le territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines on
continue avec votre chiffre du jour
Céline 36 37 quoi et puis oui le 36 37
c'est le numéro de téléphone à composer
à partir de ce vendredi 2 décembre et
pendant tout le week-end pour faire un
don à l'association AFM Téléthon on le
rappelle l'association regroupe des
malades et des parents de malades qui
luttent contre les maladies génétiques
rares évolutives et lourdement
invalidante plusieurs événements
caritatifs sont organisés dans les
Yvelines on en parlera plus tard dans
l'émission et attention si vous prévoyez
de prendre le train ce week-end un grand
mouvement social risque de compliquer
votre voyage alors oui Mathilde du
vendredi 2 au lundi 5 décembre
[Musique]
c'est quand même une ville
calme mais bon je vois sur les grandes
avenues où il y a beaucoup de passages
où les gens déjà c'était limité à 50 ne
respectent pas forcément les 50 faudrait
aussi de l'appliquer à certains
cyclistes qui vont très vite qui brûlent
les feux rouges mais à qui on autorise
tout maintenant aussi que les
automobilistes c'est vraiment la vache à
lait on nous casse les bonbons dans les
petites rues comme ici je trouve que
c'est pas mal effectivement parce qu'on
a tendance à appuyer un petit peu par
contre dans les grands axes je trouve
que 30 c'est un petit peu léger et puis
on a tendance à trop vouloir
pré-regarder le compteur et que ça
risque d'être peut-être plus plus
dangereux qu'autre chose les 30 km/h
existaient déjà finalement sur la
commune mais simplement par secteur
depuis Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse par
exemple jusqu'à château fort vous pouvez
passer sur les tronçons qui étaient à 50
30 50 avec une multiplication de
panneaux et du coup une problématique de
lisibilité de la réglement de
circulation sur la commune les habitants
nous signaler
quasiment dans toutes les réunions qu'on
peut faire le fait que ça roule trop
vite
surtout pour les personnes qui se
trouvent à pied sur les trottoirs ou à
vélo avec les enfants devant les écoles
etc
et
puis en même temps on constatait que les
vitesses finalement étaient proches de
50 km/h et on termine ces infos du jour
par des bornes de recharge pour
véhicules électriques qui vont bientôt
être installés au ciné Rocancourt
exactement c'est la société easycharge
filiale du groupe Vinci qui a été
mandaté un contrat de 10 ans a été signé
pour 30 emplacements dans la commune
accessible pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite elles seront situées à plusieurs
endroits rue des Érables rue de
Versailles boulevard Saint-Antoine ou
encore avenue de Gaulle le déploiement
devrait se faire progressivement la
première bande sera inaugurée le 9
décembre prochain merci beaucoup Céline
Charles et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous le communiquer en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
on en parlait il y a quelques instants
le premier décembre c'est la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida au
niveau national des dépistages sont au
ralenti j'ai remonterai je le rappelle
vous êtes le directeur général de HF
prévention santé c'est le cas également
dans les Yvelines les dépistages sont au
ralenti
on le voit il y a eu une démobilisation
déjà des structures qui pouvaient
potentiellement faire du dépistage les
centres de dépistage anonymé gratuit
donc ce qu'on appelle donc les CJ qui à
terme deviendront probablement
d'ailleurs des centres de santé sexuelle
ont été réacées aussi pour faire de la
vaccination covid notamment on a eu
ensuite une autre pandémie qui est
apparue durant l'été et qui a été très
vite maîtrisé qui est donc la variole du
singe le manque époque donc on en avait
déjà aussi parlé et ça a aussi mobilisé
les mêmes acteurs donc du du milieu
affectieux tout ça combiné fait que
effectivement la lutte contre le sida
fait partie des pathologies qui ont
souffert parce que du coup moins de
dépistage et donc une prise de
conscience bien moindre malgré donc les
efforts HF prévention on continue
notamment donc dans les Yvelines et on
fait partie des rares structures qui
continuent donc à faire du dépistage
nous je vous rappelle on est opérateur
donc pour le ministère de la santé mais
une fine et on le voit que ce soit en
Île-de-France ou que ce soit
particulièrement dans les Yvelines il
est encore difficile de pouvoir
reconquérir effectivement des
territoires et de pouvoir aller donc
dépister les gens d'une manière simple
tout cela engendre effectivement un très
grave retard au dépistage parce que les
gens qui sont effectivement non
découverts peuvent potentiellement donc
déclencher des cas de sida et donc
décéder et puis faire des formes de
cancer ou autre puisque du coup ça fait
partie effectivement des différentes
pathologies et en plus continue à
contaminer d'autres personnes sans le
savoir donc on va avoir effectivement
dans les années revenir un boom de de
contamination et heureusement
effectivement que les pouvoirs publics
continuent à se mobiliser et notamment
aussi les les structures type la région
wall de France autour de Valérie
Pécresse qui donc permet aussi d'avoir
des autotes des tests de France en sida
comment se faire dépister donc on peut
aujourd'hui donc se faire dépister dans
les unités mobiles d'achève prévention
que ce soit à 50 ans en Yvelines on
travaille beaucoup avec l'Université de
50 ans en Yvelines parce qu'on le
rappelle les quatre contaminations c'est
essentiellement les personnes qui sont
moins de 25 ans parce que effectivement
ils n'ont pas encore ce réflexe de
pouvoir utiliser donc le préservatif et
puis les plus de 45 ans alors santé
publique France dit les plus de 50 ans
mais en réalité la charnière c'est les
plus de 45 ans parce que il peut y avoir
des changements de vie et puis des
nouveaux comportements quand vous avez
été en couple pendant
20-25 ans et que vous retrouvez
une forme un peu différente de sexualité
bien vous allez prendre des des risques
parce que vous vous sentez pas forcément
concernés parce qu'on imagine toujours
que ça peut être les autres et c'est là
où effectivement on a des découvertes de
séropositivité donc aujourd'hui on le
dit ça devient un peu compliqué on a des
élus qui sont mobilisés notamment avec
la région Île-de-France autour de
Île-de-France sensida mais c'est pas
suffisant parce que derrière on sent que
c'est quand même quelque chose le covid
a beaucoup mobilisé sur plein de
pathologies on travaille nous en diabète
nutrition problème cardio on le voit on
a aussi donc des problèmes sur ces
pathologies là parce que du coup les
gens vont beaucoup plus penser au covid
que effectivement penser à ces maladies
qui malheureusement reste dépend des MI
et donc afin de sensibiliser les
personnes de plus de 50 ans à la
question du VIH du SIDA Sidaction lance
une campagne autour des grandes chansons
populaires françaises à laquelle
participe Lio partenaire particulier et
mille et image les artistes et leurs
paroles et ont accepté de réécrire et
réenregistrer de leur grand classique en
y intégrant un message de
sensibilisation et de prévention je vous
propose d'écouter un extrait septembre
c'est en plastique et profits
c'est facile et si rassurant c'est si
rassurant
[Musique]
pour faire la ferme débloquer pas trop
timide et une bonne dose de savoir
[Musique]
savoir faire
vous en pensez quoi Jérôme André de
partir du moment où les artistes se
mobilisent quand les chaînes de télé se
mobilisent quand effectivement les
acteurs de terrain sont présents et que
les pouvoirs publics répondent présent
on a espoir effectivement de pouvoir
relancer la prévention au cas par cas et
ses campagnes-là permettent également de
pouvoir sensibiliser très largement on
le voit le premier décembre a été un peu
éclipsé encore cette année bon on espère
que dans les années futures ça ira mieux
on a nous sorti des innovations
techniques aussi pour permettre donc aux
jeunes voilà Sacha vous étiez venu donc
filmer à l'inauguration Sacha c'est une
révolution technique puisque c'est une
vraie intelligence artificielle qui
permet d'avoir une conversation comme on
l'alla sur des problématiques de santé
sexuelle quelle qu'elle soit aujourd'hui
Sacha c'est presque 30
000 conversations chaque mois que des
gens ont effectivement et puis dans
Sacha on peut demander voilà je voudrais
me faire dépister où est-ce que je peux
me faire dépister et Sacha va pouvoir
vous répondre et vous conseiller et bien
merci merci beaucoup Jérôme André
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je le
rappelle vous êtes le directeur général
de HF prévention santé merci dans
l'actualité également le Téléthon qui
aura lieu ce week-end les trois et
quatre décembre il s'agit de la 36e
édition pour la recherche contre les
maladies génétiques rares et on en parle
avec Julie hochet vous êtes la
coordinatrice du Téléthon dans le
secteur est des Yvelines manuelamo sera
le village du Téléthon dans ce secteur
là plusieurs activités sont prévues
quels sont-elles alors à
Magny-les-Hameaux pour le week-end c'est
le week-end en Alsace donc toutes les
animations Téléthon vont tourner autour
de Noël en Alsace avec une équipe de 80
bénévoles qui va être mobilisés c'est
vraiment un vrai village qui va bouger
au rythme du Téléthon ce week-end les
enfants des écoles primaires ont été
sensibilisés cette semaine et vont
participer à une course samedi matin et
puis il y a comme d'habitude les huîtres
qui seront
vous allez déguster toute fraîche venue
de l'océan pour être dégusté pour le
Téléthon et plein d'animations de
concert de danse et d'animation pour les
jeunes et les moins jeunes
et alors cette année la jeune Nour qui a
gagné The Voice et la marraine de cette
édition tout à fait elle est la marraine
du Téléthon de Magny-les-Hameaux du
Téléthon Mani quoi et elle offrira un
concert samedi après-midi à Bali il y a
toujours une mobilisation forte autour
du Téléthon à Magny-les-Hameaux et dans
tout le secteur est des Yvelines
d'ailleurs oui on a des fidèles
désorganisateurs fidèles qui nous
propose chaque année des idées les plus
folles et les plus innovantes des défis
fous ça peut qui se mobilise pendant 24
heures 30 heures 36 heures et puis
mobilise toutes les forces vives de la
commune donc les associations sportives
les associations culturelles je l'ai dit
des écoles les sapeurs-pompiers voilà tu
veux vraiment un événement fédérateur
autour de la vie de la commune pour le
week-end alors je suis sûre que c'est
compliqué mais ce qu'il y a un
rendez-vous à ne pas manquer un seul
non en fait on a on a quasiment 300
animations autour du Téléthon donc un
seul ça c'est compliqué de dans cité cas
on va être un petit peu partout sur le
territoire et il y en a vraiment pour
tous les goûts ça peut être un tournoi
de poker un tournoi de puzzle et un
tournoi de bridge pour ceux qui veulent
faire un peu de jeux de société on va
avoir beaucoup d'événements sportifs des
trails de nuit des relais pendant 24
heures la journée des concerts des
pièces de théâtre on a pas mal
d'artistes qui seront mobilisés à nos
côtés
des sportifs aussi de haut niveau on va
Philippe on a Philippe Candeloro qui va
venir nous faire un petit coucou samedi
on a Jean-Charles trois mobiliser avec
nous sur les événements sportifs et les
relais donc voilà il y en a vraiment
pour tous les goûts est-ce que vous
voyez de nouvelles communes yvelinois se
mobilisaient pour le Téléthon oui
c'était un petit peu notre défi à la
coordination du Téléthon cette année
c'était notre objectif de convaincre des
villes qui ne faisaient pas encore le
Téléthon de proposer quelque chose alors
aux habitants on tous les ans nous on
sait un petit peu quel est le montant
des dons qui sont faits sur la
télématique ce qu'on appelle la
télématique c'est le site internet de la
FM Téléthon et le les promesses de dons
au 36 37 et donc on se rend bien compte
quels sont les villes où les habitants
sont mobilisés et c'est une cause en
fait qui qui fédère énormément les
habitants et donc on est allés voir ces
communes là et on leur a proposé de
faire quelque chose et donc deux ans
après le covid les confinements c'est
toujours quelque chose qui qui mobilise
c'est pas trop compliqué de faire
revenir les gens non parce qu'on propose
vraiment
des actions diverses et variées en fait
on est une association qui qui existe
depuis très longtemps et qui existe
grâce à la mobilisation des familles qui
ont refusé la fatalité donc en fait nous
le covid ça a été une source pour nous
de nous dépasser de réinventer ce qu'on
pouvait proposer aux gens donc les drive
sont toujours d'actualité ça a permis
aux organisateurs qui faisaient des
repas traditionnellement dans les salles
des fêtes de faire maintenant de la
prévente de billets et de proposer les
repas soit sur place soit emporter soit
en livraison donc voilà on a développé
un outil qui s'appelle la page de
collecte en ligne donc en fait ça permet
aux gens de scanner le QR code dans et
de faire un don en ligne parce qu'en
fait on a plus de monnaie ou de chèques
sur nous pour la plupart des gens donc
on se développe sur tous les outils
digitaux et en fait ça a beaucoup de
succès l'année dernière vous aviez
récolté combien environ
sur vraiment
on force nous ce qu'on appelle la force
thé vraiment les animations de terrain
on était à plus de 270 000 euros
et en tout sur alors sur toutes les
Yvelines quand on combine la force t de
terrain et la télématique on était à 2
millions d'euros d'accord et vous avez
un nouvel objectif cette année alors
cette année on aimerait bien nous en
tant que société dépasser les 300.000
euros et revenir au chiffre de 2019 ce
sera un beau challenge merci Julie ou
chez d'être venu un plateau pour en
parler je le rappelle vous êtes la
coordinatrice du Téléthon dans le
secteur est des Yvelines et comme chaque
année les communes yvelinoises et leurs
associations sont très mobilisées pour
le Téléthon parcours marche réflexologie
atelier de fabrication d'huile
essentielle à Guyancourt ou des
animations se tiennent du vendredi au
dimanche avec un temps fort la soirée du
samedi au pavillon au Waldeck rousse aux
Clayes-sous-Bois soirée dansante
démonstration sportive et initiation au
rugby cette année d'ailleurs le parrain
du Téléthon klétien et Jean-Claude
screla ancien joueur et sélectionneur du
15 de France 24 heures de Marathon
également à Magny-les-Hameaux du
vendredi 18h30 au samedi 19h30 c'est au
gymnase Chantal Mauduit le thème cette
année l'Alsace et la chanteuse nous
revainqueur de The Voice 2022 chantera
de chantera l'événement pour la première
fois à Montigny-le-Bretonneux un fil
rouge ponctura le week-end un défi
escalade de 24 heures non-stop du
vendredi 18h au samedi 18h le village
Téléthon et ses animations se tiendront
toute la journée de samedi au Centre
sportif Pierre de Coubertin l'union fait
la force à Saint-Cyr l'école Bois-d'Arcy
et Fontenay-le-Fleury les trois villes
se regroupent pour proposer des
activités à l'Espace Gérard Philipe
enfin un voisin un homme Bretonneux le
gros du programme se déroule le samedi
au Centre sportif les pyramides mais dès
le vendredi un Tournoi des Trois
raquettes se tient au Parc des Sports
Maurice et si vous souhaitez faire un
don vous pouvez le faire en appelant le
36 37 ou en ligne sur
don.teleton.fr et avec nous dans cette
suite Philippe Benassaya bonsoir vous
êtes le porte-parole du Conseil
départemental des Yvelines nous allons
parler notamment de la 5e édition du
comptoir de Noël qui va se dérouler au
domaine de Madame Élisabeth à Versailles
mais avant cela nous allons parler
politique avec vous ce sera ce week-end
se déroule le premier tour du congrès du
parti les républicains les militants
sont appelés à voter pour le futur
président du parti en ligne ou dans les
points d'accueil physique ils auront le
choix entre Bruno Retailleau Aurélien
Pradier ou Éric Ciotti est-ce que vous
avez fait un choix est-ce que vous avez
vous allez soutenir un candidat alors
d'abord la transition un peu compliquée
parce qu'on a quand même parlé de choses
très sensibles comme vos combats que
vous menez et le téléthon nous sommes
tous élus locaux mobilisés sur sur le
Téléthon dans mon canton de bois d'Ar
vous l'avez rappelé on est on sera très
mobilisé donc transition un peu sensible
mais on va quand même parler un peu
politique et c'est important c'est très
important parce que c'est une grande
famille politique les républicains issus
d'une d'une belle tradition gaulliste
donc c'est pas une une élection anonyme
vous allez dire que je vais faire une
une réponse de langue de bois mais c'est
pas du tout mon habitude c'est que
d'abord je suis vice-président des
républicains 70 donc j'ai un devoir de
réserve par rapport au prochain futur
président qui va être élu donc il faudra
travailler avec lui mais je pense que
sur le fond je vais vous répondre sur le
fond le sujet et le suivant
quel que soit le président qui sera élu
je sois irisotti ou Bruno Retailleau ou
Aurélien Pradier le travail est immense
qui nous attend il est pas forcément
politique parce qu'en fait quand on voit
à la carte des Yvelines voir ailleurs
l'implantation des républicains est
plutôt plutôt satisfaisante nous avons
des villes nous avons des agglomérations
nous dirigeons des régions nous
dirigeons un département dont notamment
celui de des Yvelines donc
l'implantation locale est plutôt est
plutôt forte il y a deux problèmes qui
nous handicapent depuis des années le
premier problème c'est le problème
culturel qui sommes-nous que
devenons-nous et où allons-nous et
qu'est-ce qu'être de droite aujourd'hui
et qu'est-ce qu'être républicain
aujourd'hui que ce soit ceux qui
Retailleau Pradier il faudra répondre à
cette question il vous reste peu
d'espace j'ai envie de dire entre le
le parti de Macron plutôt libéral et le
parti plutôt souverainisme de Marine Le
Pen c'est ça parce qu'en fait je vous
rappelle que les républicains sont issus
d'une déjà d'une alliance qui était
l'alliance de l'UDF et du RPR qui est
devenu l'UMP avec toutes ses composantes
libérales radicales conservatrice
souverainiste une partie a été captée
par des parties plus souverainistes une
partie a été captée par un par le Centre
on va dire macroniste et donc on ne sait
plus qui qui fait quoi et comment on est
perçu et ça c'est la vraie question
alors franchement très honnêtement je
leur réponds c'est pas la langue de bois
ce soit ciothyroteil ou Pradier ils
devront faire ce travail de de
visibilité et puis et de culture qui
sommes-nous et la deuxième question et
c'est là où on est le handicap c'est que
nous n'avons pas de leadership c'est
pour ça que nous sommes très fort
localement mais que nationalement nous
perdons pourquoi nous perdons d'abord
parce nous n'avons pas fait de
travailler culturel et ce travail de
d'identité mais en plus surtout parce
que nous n'avons pas un leader qui à
chaque fois rassemble nous l'avions en
2017 avec François Fillon mais ce que
vous avez vu leur parquet national
financier qui a été d'une extrême
rapidité d'exécution dans une campagne
électorale bizarrement
et puis depuis il y a une sorte de
descente aux enfers on n'arrive pas à
retrouver un leader qui puisse incarner
ce courant de droitier très probablement
majoritaire dans le pays
retrouver dans les Yvelines par un des
trois candidats
pourquoi pas oui peut-être quelqu'un
d'autre Éric Ciotti vous avez entendu
que s'il était président DLR
soutiendrait Laurent Wauquiez ça peut
être quelqu'un d'autre nous sommes loin
comme des présidentielles je sais que
les journalistes sont très très
focalisés sur les présidentielles même 5
ans avant c'est la question qu'on nous
pose tout de suite qui sera le futur
président de la République j'avoue que
j'avais pas vu arriver Emmanuel Macron
un an avant donc je me je me
pronostiquerai pas là-dessus mais c'est
surtout le travail qu'il faut faire
avant retrouver un grand parti retrouver
une identité retrouver une culture
politique que nous avons perdue et après
trouver un leader qui incarne ce tout ce
courant politique de droite qui est
honnêtement majoritaire dans le pays
Philippe Benassaya va mettre fin fin à
cette page politique on va passer à
notre page loisir où on va parler du
comptoir de Noël au domaine de Madame
Elisabeth
[Musique]
ce week-end je le disais se déroule la
5e édition du comptoir de Noël au
domaine de Madame Élisabeth à Versailles
alors je vous le demandais au tout début
d'émission qu'est-ce quelles sont les
activités qui étaient prévues au total
il y aura combien de stands environ à
peu près 90 donc comme je le disais tout
à l'heure on a mis le paquet cette année
le département
tient énormément à ce à cette à ce
moment nous allons créer un véritable
village de Noël dans le domaine de
Madame Elisabeth avec un parcours un
parcours sucré un parcours salé parcours
de jeux pour enfants des foutres des
animations je pense que ça va être un
vrai un vrai moment convivial et
familial
et vous attendez beaucoup de monde oui
je pense que cette année il va y avoir
du monde parce qu'on monte en gamme dans
cette dans cet événement de marché de
Noël et c'est vrai que le département a
mis a mis les moyens pour pour
rassembler les familles yvelinoises au
domaine malgré ce contexte d'inflation
oui malgré ce contexte d'inflation mais
bon on peut pas tout mettre sur le dos
de l'inflation et de la crise
on sort d'une crise sanitaire maintenant
on a une crise énergétique de Mario run
crise autre et puis on aurait une autre
crise et à chaque fois on aura un
réflexe de de repli qui n'est pas bon
pour un peuple de se replier et je pense
qu'il faut justement au contraire c'est
dans les moments de crise qu'il faut
investir
j'étais maire pendant longtemps de
Bois-d'Arcy
j'ai été maire à une période où il y
avait une crise économique très très
importante et c'est à ce moment-là qu'on
nous avons investi pourquoi je dis ça
parce que il faut aussi donner aux
familles il faut donner aussi aux
yvelinois l'envie de sortir l'EN l'envie
de vivre en famille de rencontrer de
l'envie de partager de donner le goût de
la solidarité de la convivialité et
c'est pas parce qu'il y a une crise
qu'il faut rester touche chez soi sinon
on vit plus quoi c'est un rendez-vous
attendu important des versaillers et des
yvelinois plus en général alors on a
constaté que bien sûr majorité il y
avait des Versailles mais beaucoup
d'Yves Linois aussi qui viennent à ce
marché Noël qui est devenu manoir
rendez-vous incontournable qui monte
chaque année l'année prochaine vous fera
peut-être encore mieux l'année dernière
on a fait un petit peu moins et c'est
vrai qu'on est en train de monter 90 ans
de c'est beaucoup quand même avec
énormément d'animations énormément de
surprises et puis je pense que les
enfants vont passer un très très bon
moment merci Philippe et je vous en prie
merci à vous pour en parler avec nous on
continue sur le thème de Noël puisque la
ferme de Gally de Saint-Cyr l'école à
tronquer ses citrouilles pour ses
illuminations de Noël depuis le 19
novembre et jusqu'au 18 décembre inclut
la ferme ouvre ses portes et au plus
grand pour son événement Noël et
merveille plusieurs ateliers sont
proposés découvrez-les avec Céline
Charles les derniers vestiges
d'Halloween trônent encore et pourtant
c'est une toute autre ambiance qui s'est
installée à la ferme de Gally guirlandes
et lumière le prouve Noël est à
l'approche
[Musique]
comme chaque année la ferme propose tous
les samedis et dimanche après-midi de
nombreux ateliers à l'occasion de son
événement Noël et merveille pour 13,5
euros les enfants peuvent s'initier à la
boulangerie et à la confection de
décoration de Noël tout en côtoyant les
animaux de la ferme c'est une petite
couronne voilà ils ont fait une petite
couronne raphia où ils ont dû créer
composer voilà donc on nous fournit le
matériel et il compose comme ils veulent
un petit sapin elle a collé elle a mis
et des petites guirlandes des plumes et
une rondelle d'orange une atmosphère
féérique voulue par l'équipe et qui fait
le bonheur de toute la famille une
ambiance un peu chaleureuse avec les
deux corps lumineux l'esprit un peu de
Noël on se retrouve on partage un bon
moment et puis les enfants repartent
surtout avec quelque chose à la maison
pour pour montrer aux personnes qui
n'ont pas pu venir avec eux et puis
surtout pour mettre un peu de déco chez
eux je voulais faire une activité avec
mes enfants en plus qui
rappelle Noël donc c'était parfait et
puis on est à Paris donc on est aussi
content de sortir un petit peu de voilà
de Paris et de faire petite activité
voilà en plein air faire profiter des
activités à ma petite fille qui a 3 ans
et lui montrer les belles décorations de
Noël ça leur permet de voir de faire
d'autres choses et donner des idées
aussi aux parents de sortir crêpes et
jus de pomme chaud à la cannelle vous
attendent à la ferme de Gally une
activité à retrouver jusqu'au 18
décembre
[Musique]
on poursuit dans l'ambiance de Noël
c'est un des premiers rendez-vous du
département le marché de Noël de
Coignières a encore attiré de nombreux
visiteurs les samedis au 26 et dimanche
27 novembre de multiples animations et
temps forts
avec bien sûr la présence du Père Noël
c'est aussi un reportage de Céline
Charles il était de retour pour un
week-end le marché de Noël de Coignières
a lancé les festivités dans la ville
grand sapin illumination ou encore
artisanat d'hiver était au programme un
cocktail féerique pour ravir les
habitants venus en nombre malgré la
pluie on commence à profiter
tranquillement des préparatifs de Noël
se mettent un peu dans l'ambiance voilà
c'est un beau marché qui est bien décoré
donc on tous les ans on vient ici et on
en profite avec les petits animaux les
chevaux le Père Noël bah pour les
enfants les la mini ferme là comme ils
font et tous les exposants
le Père Noël pour les enfants qui est
très attendu un marché où chacun a ses
préférences
qu'est-ce que tu peux faire sur le
marché de Noël bah je les bonbons au
total 28 particuliers et producteurs
locaux ont répondu présent plusieurs
exposants venaient d'ailleurs de
Coignières c'était une volonté de la
municipalité sur mon stand j'ai tout un
tas de produits de la ruche en fait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui avec avec tout ce qu'on
connaît en pénurie de d'énergie et tout
ça c'est important et puis ça permet
aussi de faire vivre les petites les
petites communes d'avoir une activité
locale sur les petites communes il y a
des sapins de Noël fait avec du coton
démaquillant et après dessus je rajoute
des décos j'aime bien l'ambiance de Noël
et puis et puis c'est sympa c'est
familial sans oublier bien sûr le Père
Noël venu tout droit de Laponie je viens
rendre une petite visite à mes futurs
mes futurs petits enfants que je vais
livrer gentiment que je vais pouvoir
récolter un peu des idées pour prévoir
la construction au niveau des lutins
avec une question que je pose tous
même les plus grands donc il y aura
énormément de cadeaux en attendant les
nombreux cadeaux sous le sapin d'autres
rendez-vous festifs sont prévus dans le
département prochaines dates le marché
de Noël de la Ferme du Manet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux du vendredi 2
décembre au dimanche 4 décembre
[Musique]
et après Coignières d'autres communes
organisent leur marché de Noël en
décembre des weekends rendez vous au
samedi à La Verrière sur le parvis
scarabée à Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce
sera trois jours de festivités de
vendredi à dimanche à la Ferme du Manet
et l'encours organise également à son
événement pendant trois jours ce sera du
9 au 11 décembre sur le parvis de
l'Hôtel de Ville un marché de Noël aussi
à Guyancourt mais un marché solidaire
pour la ville jumelée de Komé au Bénin
c'est le 10 entre 10h et 17h gros
programme en perspective pour le
week-end du 9 au 11 décembre puisque
Maurepas et plaisir proposeront
également leur animation à Maurepas est
au gymnase de La malmedone et à plaisir
c'est dans le parc du château la commune
des Clayes-sous-Bois revient avec la
deuxième édition de son marché du 16 au
18 décembre place Charles de Gaulle et
sur le parvis de l'espace Philippe
Noiret enfin attrape le marché de Noël
se tiendra pendant une semaine sur la
place de la Merise à chaque fois entre
14h et 18h30 pour la première fois
d'ailleurs la ville proposera une
patinoire synthétique dans la salle de
la Merise et Gabriel vous nous avez de
nouveau rejoint en plateau est-ce que
vous avez préparé vos idées de cadeaux
pour Noël alors pour étonné je m'y
prends souvent au dernier moment donc
pour l'instant pas du tout mais que le
premier décembre donc j'ai encore un peu
le temps c'est pareil je fais partie de
ces personnes qui le 24 au soir cours
dans les magasins pour essayer de
trouver les derniers cadeaux comme
beaucoup de gens je suis un petit peu
parée peut-être pas le 24 au soir mais
oui je le fais généralement la dernière
semaine avant le 25 en tout cas bah tous
ces marchés de Noël pourront nous
peut-être nous aider à trouver des
cadeaux et on reste dans une ambiance
hivernale partir au sport d'hiver dans
les Yvelines c'est possible c'est ce que
vous propose le parc alpin à côté 2100
installé dans le premier depuis le 1er
novembre sur l'île des Impressionnistes
de Chatou il vous propose de multiples
activités ludiques qui luge ou encore
raclette en téléphérique c'est lynchaal
vous avez testé plusieurs activités j'ai
testé la patinoire la luge tant bien que
mal acquis et bien sûr le repas bien
dans une télécabine c'est ça je vous
propose de découvrir ces activités
ensemble
[Musique]
faire du ski à quelques minutes de Paris
c'est possible sur l'île des
Impressionnistes de Chatou je me trouve
actuellement au parc alpin à côté 2100
ce qui raclette ou encore patinoire
venait découvrir avec moi ces nombreux
activités
[Musique]
je me trouve actuellement avec Céline
Caillat directrice de la communication
et marketing de ce superbe endroit alpin
du coup village alpin qu'est-ce que
c'est un petit peu ce que vous pouvez me
présenter du coup qu'est-ce qu'on y
trouve la première station d'hiver de
l'Ouest parisien on y trouve trois sites
dans un site une piste de luge une piste
de ski avec biathlon une piste de ski
alpin et une grande patinoire de 500
mètres carrés le parc afterwork avec
trois bars et des DJ à partir de 17
heures le soir et la troisième partie
qui est le domaine de la restauration
avec 150 télécabines et plus de 10
téléphérique qui vont de 8 à 16
personnes de 11 heures le matin à 23h30
on peut venir déjeuner à partir de 11
heures le matin et toute la journée
c'est un service continu en télécabine
et le soir à partir de 19h en télécabine
pour fondue et raclette c'est vraiment
l'ambiance du ski avec les produits
savoyard un grand sourcing savoyard tous
les produits viennent de savoir et c'est
pour tout public et c'est pour tout
public loin des tout petits c'est
gratuit pour les moins de 5 ans et on
fait un droit d'entrée mais qu'on
appelle le Pass entré de 10 euros mais
qui a un bon de consommation c'est pas
une vraie entrée c'est vraiment pour
consommer sur place pour avoir droit à
une attraction à des crêpes et chocolats
chauds et du coup pour la patinoire pour
la consommation d'énergie aussi des
télécabines comment vous avez un petit
peu aménagé ça fait 500 mètres carrés
oui de patinoire un travail avec une
très belle société qui s'appelle
cinerglass où la consommation d'énergie
équivaut à trois foyers de 4 personnes
sur un mois et surtout en tel cabine on
a retiré tous les chauffages qui étaient
présents dans les télécabines les 150
télécabines n'ont pas de chauffage c'est
pour ça qu'on demande nos clients de
jouer le jeu de venir en tenue de ski et
puis on fournit les plaids tous les
jours et le vin chaud moi ça m'a donné
envie en tout cas je ne sais pas où mais
moi je vais aller tester ces activités
bonjour est-ce que ce serait possible de
faire du patin s'il vous plaît
c'est parti
[Musique]
après la patinoire un petit passage par
la piste de luge de plus de 4 mètres de
haut et 25 mètres de long
je me suis rendu sur la piste de ski un
tapis roulant en revêtement synthétique
qui permet de s'initier ou de retrouver
des sensations
après l'effort le réconfort en
télécabine avec une carte savoyarde
appétissante ce sera fondu à la truffe
pour cette fois-ci
si vous n'avez pas la chance de partir
au sport d'hiver à la montagne pas de
panique vous pouvez venir vous initier
ou pratiquer ici jusqu'au 29 janvier
prochain
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par ATIS Barret bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes conseiller en municipal à Poissy
délégué à la biodiversité au bien-être
animal dans quelques instants vous allez
nous présenter une chronique sur la
nourriture qu'on peut donner à nos
chiens ou non tout à fait rejoint
également par Nicolas dandry bonsoir
journaliste de la rédaction alors moi
j'ai une question est-ce que ça vous a
donné envie de tester certaines
activités autour du plateau
plus
et puis manger un télécabine c'est pas
mal c'est une idée originale
effectivement
Athis moi aussi je suis très gourmande
alors manger en cabine en plus il y a
coupure d'électricité on mange dans la
cabine tranquille voilà et vous Nicolas
ça a l'air sympathique
ce qui faut faire attention aux genoux
quoi
c'est très sportif c'est 15 minutes mais
il nous a dit que les personnes étaient
fatiguées au bout de 4 minutes donc
voilà je vous propose de passer à la
chronique sur le bien-être de nos chers
compagnons les chiens vous allez venir
régulièrement à this pour faire des
chroniques sur le bien-être de nos
animaux domestiques en tout cas on
commence par cette chronique sur vous
allez nous donner des conseils sur
l'alimentation de nos chiens
généralement on s'embête on s'embête pas
trop on leur donne des croquettes alors
est-ce que c'est une bonne chose ou non
alors effectivement moi je suis un
Mathilde on a tendance à donner des
croquettes à nos chiens peut-être faute
de temps mais en réalité les
vétérinaires il y a déjà quelques années
étaient très choquée par la venue de ces
paquets qui considéraient comme des
graines pour chien le n'oublions pas que
le chien également prend plaisir à
manger et quand c'est bon il mange quand
c'est pas bon il ne mange pas donc
vous revrez pour le plaisir pour le goût
de son chien et sa bonne santé il
faudrait ressortir nos tabliers et
cuisiner pour son chien également
n'oublions pas que ce qui est bon pour
la santé de l'humain et également
valable pour son chien le canidé est un
carnivore n'hésitez pas à lui proposer
des carcasses alors est-ce qu'il faut
les cuire avant de leur donner ou non
très bonne question surtout ne pas cuire
les os de poulet les os en général car
le chien en fait avec la force de sa
mâchoire en croquant très fort pourrait
se blesser avec les morceaux donc ce
qu'il faut il vaut mieux laisser l'os
dur le chien va détendre sa mâchoire
avec on va se soulager la mâchoire avec
l'os et puis également il va détartrer
ses dents
on a également constaté qu'un chien qui
mange est cru avait des déjections
canines qui sentaient moins fort moins
odorante et moins importante ça c'est
peut-être une bonne solution pour notre
trottoir en ville et puis cuisiner ça
permet de diversifier
ses vitamines de mettre un maximum de
vitamines de maîtriser les produits
également de maîtriser le coût le coup
en général maintenant les boîtes
également sont une excellente
alternative il y a à l'intérieur de la
chair de poisson des fruits des légumes
des produits laitiers car on conserve
avec les boîtes la saveur également les
produits ne sont pas déshydratés alors
est-ce qu'on peut quand même leur donner
des croquettes ou non oui on peut bien
sûr leur donner des croquettes elles
sont complètes mais surtout demandez
l'avis à votre vétérinaire il vous
donnera la bonne posologie en fonction
du poids de l'âge si votre chien fait de
l'attention de l'obés et vous donnera le
bon calibrage vous pouvez également vous
documenter avec de très bons livres en
février 2023 du ressortira dans les
éditions de la Martinière babine canine
de Valérie Drouet qui va vous donner des
conseils c'est tout nouveau les conseils
pour cuisiner pour son chien et bien sûr
vous choisirez le repas idéal avec en
observant vous-même la qualité du pelage
sa musculature physique son humeur sa
joie ce qui vous bout en ce moment
est-ce que c'est celle sont bonnes ou
pas et sa fin et attention parce que
l'effet arrivent ne donnaient surtout
pas de chocolat à votre chien pas de
boissons alcoolisées pas de café
l'oignon l'ail ça peut être Martel ça
peut être mortel pour vos chiens et bien
merci beaucoup Baptiste Barry d'être
venu nous donner vos conseils sur le
plateau on vous retrouvera tout dans 15
jours environ pour pour une nouvelle
chronique est-ce que vous savez déjà de
quoi vous allez nous parler alors ce
sera une chronique qui sera réservée aux
cadeaux de de Noël pour vos chiens pour
vos animaux en général alors sans
dévoiler toute la chronique est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut offrir comme cadeau
par exemple il y a des pour les chats
par exemple pour les amuser un petit peu
vous avez des petits lasers qui font de
la lumière ça les fera courir un peu
mais on en parlera dans une quinzaine de
jours on va passer à notre page loisirs
enfin continue cette page loisir avec
vous Gabriel vous nous avez préparé 5
idées de sortie dans les Yvelines par
quoi on commence et ben je vous propose
Mathilde de commencer le week-end en
musique la ville de Thoiry propose
vendredi soir un concert symphonique au
total 55 musiciens seront présents sur
scène reprenant les grandes œuvres de
Mozart comme cosy fan toutay ou encore
celle de César Franck cet orchestre est
en association avec le Conservatoire à
Rayonnement Régional de Rueil-Malmaison
un établissement reconnu pour son
enseignement musical de renommée qui
forme chaque année des artistes du monde
entier et toujours en musique les
solistes de la Villedieu seront à
Trappes ce tout à fait c'est le premier
concert de la saison
2022-2023 au programme un voyage musical
sur le thème de l'Heure Bleue leur bleue
c'est ce moment de silence entre la fin
de la nuit et le jour qui se lève dans
ce projet Marianne picotti et les
musiciens mélangent les œuvres et les
inspirations pour nous plonger dans une
expérience sensorielle et intellectuelle
tout l'enjeu pour les solistes de la
ville-dieu qui depuis 2002 œuvre pour
faire sortir la musique des grandes
sales parisiennes en l'ouvrant à tout le
monde et en approchant un nouveau public
du coup les prix sont accessibles oui il
faut compter 8 euros à partir de 12 ans
et 18 euros pour les adultes avec un
tarif réduit pour les seniors ce qui
pour un concert de musique classique et
effectivement assez accessible au
programme de ce week-end des expositions
également tout à fait je vais vous
parler de la 157e du 157e salon des
artistes qui se tient à Versailles cette
année encore la société Versailles des
artistes d'Île-de-France qui est de une
des plus contiennent associations
artistique française réunis les artistes
professionnels et amateurs
d'Île-de-France alors pendant deux
semaines dessinateur graveur sculpteur
ou encore peintre sont réunis sur la
soixantaine d'artistes d'îles de France
23 viennent des Yvelines alors parmi les
artistes mis à l'honneur cette année on
retrouve la rambolitaine Daniel Dekeyser
connu pour ses sculptures de bronze à
noter Mathilde que samedi à 16h30 aura
lieu une remise des prix aux artistes et
alors elle n'est pas artiste Gabriel
mais autrice et elle vient à la
rencontre de ses lecteurs oui pour la
dixième édition du Prix Roman des
étudiants organisé par Télérama et
France Culture la scénariste
réalisatrice et romancière Lucie Rico
auteur du chant du poulet sous vide ou
encore du roman GPS une fiction sur les
angoisses et la géolocalisation teintées
de beaucoup d'humour noir elle vient à
la rencontre de ses lecteurs à la
médiathèque du canal de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas le prix
du roman des étudiants c'est un prix
littéraire dans lequel les juges sont
les étudiants alors parmi les nombreuses
universités engagées celles de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines d'octobre à
décembre les auteurs vont à la rencontre
des étudiants alors c'est visite elles
sont bénéfiques pour les étudiants mais
aussi pour le grand public puisque les
auteurs se rendent également dans les
bibliothèques alentours et pour terminer
Gabriel vous nous plonger un peu plus
encore dans les fêtes de fin d'année
avec la fête des lumières vous nous en
aviez parlé il y a quelques jours après
la préparation place au spectacle oui
après les ateliers de confection de
lanterne place à la déambulation de la
Fête des Lumières alors cette année
Guyancourt vous plonge dans un univers
fantastique poétique et coloré après le
défilé du cortège un spectacle pour les
petits et les grands sera proposé merci
beaucoup Gabriel Gontier est-ce que
autour du plateau vous avez une
préférence dans toutes ses activités
je pense que je partirai sur la fête des
lumières ça a l'air très joli
l'exposition d'artistes à Versailles
sympathique
fait des lumières aussi la fête des
lumières ça fait ça fait l'unanimité je
crois Nicolas dandry comme d'habitude le
jeudi vous nous préparer un quiz et je
crois que cette semaine il est sur les
marchés de Noël
voilà le pull de Noël on va parler des
marchés de Noël et on va faire un voyage
dans le temps vous allez voir soyez
attentifs aux images soyez attentifs à
ce que vous entendez aussi parce que
voilà c'est ça peut être la réponse
voilà il peut y avoir des indices vous
êtes prêtes
[Applaudissements]
il y a pas d'indice mais il faut
regarder faut être attentif aux images
on va voyager dans le temps vous qui
êtes sur les réseaux sociaux vous pouvez
aussi jouer tout de suite ces images
nous sommes en 2006 soyez donc bien
attentif regardez bien ces images de ce
marché de Noël à votre avis quelle
commune limitrophe à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux organise son
premier marché de Noël cette année là je
rappelle qu'on est en 2006
question compliquée pour commencer
vous avez une idée de cette commune
limitrophe à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
Saint-Cyr-l'École qui va s'afficher à
l'écran voilà donc sincère l'école
effectivement qui organisait son premier
marché de Noël en 2006
deuxième question regardons ce reportage
sur le marché de Noël des
Clayes-sous-Bois c'était en 2009 et
écoutez bien une très bonne clientèle
des gens toujours aussi adorables des
compliments toujours et c'est toujours
agréable d'être là quoi un week-end
réservé aux créateurs aux communs du
château des Clayes-sous-Bois ce marché
de Noël leur propose chaque année depuis
plus de 10 ans d'exposer leur
savoir-faire on y trouve donc surtout
des idées de cadeaux de petits tableaux
des accessoires des bijoux en perles de
verre de Murano ou encore des objets de
décoration il y a beaucoup de couleurs
il y a beaucoup d'idées et j'ai réussi
pour toutes les bourses donc les enfants
les jeunes et puis bien sûr les adultes
on peut toujours trouver quelque chose à
offrir c'est vrai que c'est dans leur
vie de temps le marché de Noël nous nous
avions innové ça fait une dizaine ou une
douzaine d'années donc effectivement
continue dans notre lancée la direction
de la de la de notre association a
changé mais
voilà donc on était en 2009 marché de
Noël des Clayes-sous-Bois à votre avis
vous avez si vous avez bien écouté
combien il y avait d'exposants
Mathilde mathilde a répondu en première
bravo l'extrait on écoute la réponse
cette année dont une grande majorité
habituée de ce marché de Noël des Clayes
bon ces questions de rapidité troisième
question toujours en images direction
les ferries féeries de Noël de 2008 une
fête avec des activités en famille pour
les parents les enfants et puis on va
voir à la fin le spectacle pour conclure
l'après-midi mais à votre avis dans
quelle commune se déroule c'est féeries
de Noël
[Musique]
et on voit le spectacle nocturne
on a vu quelques indices pour deviner la
commune quand même
non ce n'est pas Élancourt
les féeries de Noël de 2008
une idée commune de 50 ans en Yvelines
en cours c'est quoi toujours
bon vous n'avez pas la réponse et bien
c'était trap
on a vu quelques images de la mairie
notamment parce que c'est fait ery de
Noël se tenait dans la mairie la mairie
de trappes et donc tous les Trappistes
étaient invités à fêter Noël à la mairie
quatrième question c'est un marché de
Noël traditionnel dans cette ville un
rendez-vous incontournable avec de plus
en plus d'exposants chaque année vous
voyez les images sur quel site
historique se déroule ce marché de Noël
qui a donné la réponse effectivement on
va voir tout de suite la réponse
affichée la Ferme du Manet vous êtes
très fort ce soir sur ce quiz assez
simple un peu plus simple que les
derniers quiz effectivement la Ferme du
Manet qui se situe à Montigny
d'ailleurs dans le reportage de 2009 sur
la question c'est pour ça que je vous
avais dit de bien écouter parce qu'il y
a des indices un peu partout ce soir
cinquième question une animation que
vous retrouvez souvent sur les marchés
de Noël la patinoire
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire où se
situe cette patinoire qu'on voit à
l'image et puis en plus le tournage a
été réalisé l'année dernière
effectivement
[Musique]
où se situe cette patinoire donc il n'y
ait pas à l'année c'est d'installer
uniquement pour Noël
vous avez payé je sais que c'est pas une
commune de 50 ans en Yvelines enfin
c'est une commune de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines je crois c'est
une commune de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
c'est à la Commanderie oui Mathilde
bravo la Commanderie elle en cours
effectivement qui l'année dernière donc
accueillait une patinoire pour célébrer
Noël allez dernière question on reste
dans le monde de la patinoire et je vous
propose de regarder ces images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà des images encore piocher dans les
archives de TV 78 alors je ne vais pas
vous demander où se situe la patinoire
parce que c'est trop simple c'est dans
l'espace Saint-Quentin autour du centre
commercial de Saint-Quentin en face de
la médiathèque mais est-ce que vous
pouvez me dire quel coût quelle est la
couleur du chapeau de la fille qui est
tombé plusieurs fois
elle avait un manteau rose
non est-ce que vous avez été attentif on
la voit tomber plusieurs fois cette
jeune fille la pauvre
elle avait un chapeau de quelle couleur
il était précis vos questions
[Musique]
le chapeau et violet on va le voir voilà
effectivement le château des Mathilde 4
points ce soir
je vous l'avoue pour une question on m'a
soufflé la réponse dans l'oreillette
mais sinon les trois autres c'est j'ai
trouvé toute seule mais bravo Mathilde
bravo voilà on en apprend un peu plus
alors on va de plus en plus piocher dans
les archives de TV 78 pour aller encore
plus loin dans la découverte de la
culture yvelinoise notamment la culture
maintenant historique parce qu'on peut
réutiliser ces images de télé 78 et je
peux vous confier que j'en ai énormément
et j'en ai déjà mis de côté on attendra
beaucoup avec impatience Nicolas tandry
merci beaucoup c'est bientôt la fin de
cette émission mais juste avant de se
quitter je vous propose de jeter un coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
l'hiver s'installe dans les Yvelines
demain matin le ciel devrait rester
encore bien nuageux sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
couvrez-vous bien parce qu'il devrait
faire en moyenne 3 à 2 degrés dans
l'après-midi pas de gros changements le
ciel devrait rester couvert au niveau
des températures comptez 3 degrés en
moyenne dans les Yvelines et dans la
nuit du vendredi au samedi quelques
flocons devraient faire leurs
apparitions dans les Yvelines Gabriel
Gonthier quel est le temps de ce
week-end et bien Mathilde samedi le ciel
sera voilé sur l'ensemble du département
du côté des températures elles seront
comprises entre 1 et 3 degrés dans la
matinée l'après-midi le temps reste
nuageux il fera 3 degrés à Versailles et
Rambouillet et 4 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan dimanche des
éclaircies apparaîtront dans la matinée
mais la plus fait son retour comptez 1
degré à Rambouillet de à Mantes et à
Versailles l'après-midi il fera 2 degrés
à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles ou dans et
Rambouillet merci Gabriel Gontier c'est
la fin de cette émission merci pour
votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]